hey guys how we doing I'm here with row
no I'm actually at her house right now
into her setup so thank you so much for
letting me feel good I'm so excited that
you're here
so we also filmed a really fun video on
our channel so I'll put links in the
description and links to all things row
you're just like my favorite like I love
going via with you because they're
always so much fun I know we have a
black we do even got steam today with
the windows I blew up some rolls
purple one oh well helium in there
that's money floating around in theme a
Valentine's Day I thought we could make
ourselves Valentine's Day card so I'm
going to make one for you and you can
make one for me okay I like forcing
people to make cards for me it's great
no I wait done right anyways it was a
few days away this is a great idea but
there is you know a little odd twist
we're going to throw into it and we
always do blindfolded challenges on your
channel I thought we need to do one
today and we're going to blindfold
ourselves mm-hmm and here's all of our
items everything that was on sale I was
like let's put it into my basket just
see you got some goodies what is in this
bag okay what's going on here and we've
got markers we've got stickers we've got
tape and of course we're getting
blindfold and logician we have to be
very very very very very careful okay so
we're gonna we're going to be
blindfolded just making Valentines for
each other
yes okay you left-handed or right-handed
I'm right-handed okay so any time you
write anything you have to write with
your left hand
oh and I'm one unit so I will write with
my right hand okay be right are gonna be
made with a lot of love I am predicting
this are gonna be a hot mess
you know I don't know there's also this
glue Sween oh it's gorgeous classic
glitter glue and it's pink beautiful
perfect for Valentine's Day the paper oh
okay myself because you can't see who we
just gonna have to kind of try to feel
we're gonna give out cards retail so
let's start off with this as a video and
we'll just add chilli okay get all the
goodies out here too
oh my oh boy working with
oh here we are a guy again right mindset
just taking an inventory of what we've
got here okay all right and again be
careful with the scissors okay
I just got me oh wow Valentine's Day I'm
making a car for Justine and I make it
beautiful
okay so we've got our paper oh boy let's
do we start with okay I'm going to fold
mine so it's like an actual card oh I
want to play one boom okay mom making
you a poster okay I supposed to tell you
the pan okay there's more shine let me
keep on supplying win men must die I
don't want the feeling of paper like
it's dry I don't like it there's some
shiny stuff over here
whew okay feels dry I'm hoping so this
is the red heart paper so I'm doing
something super crafty what do you feel
with you doing well I can't tell you
okay I'm tempting to cut out a heart and
what happened oh no like that is what I
am doing okay so wait holding this in
half then I got look feel that's what
I'm doing looky I'm holding in half and
nothing more oh yeah you did you learn
this trick soon I can't wait no cool
yeah as you fold the paper in half and
then you take your scissors and you cut
out half of a heart and then it will be
symmetrical
exactly okay got my scissors
okay nicely guess what a heart looks
like oh I'm so scared I'm going to cut
my fingers because I can't see this is
dangerous
don't try this at home oh now we've got
to use that this is going to look like
all this feels like a heart the video
good this is good
funny glue yeah that's a good one
I got me greed you three go six
somewhere but you know I there's a
marker I need to find a glue let me
knock you find okay um what's this it is
different what is it are we calling the
same thing we're Yuval what are you
holding wait I just took the lid off oh
wait oh oh that's not glue what are you
holding to me wait I'm going to same
thing I know I just touched it's not
sticky it is wet I think it's like a pen
oh he's got a big glue that's kind of
glue oh I found a big glue I come with
the glue okay I don't really whisk in my
hand but I like it breathing over what
he can see me okay okay I'm taping on my
heart hopefully avoid put some glue on
here okay I want to write your name on
it
yeah ro I need to write you a note glue
okay look this is what big glue or wood
you got I got a big glue
oh wow wow wow I want to oppose those
friends nope not open gotta open you're
done but I got it right with my opposite
hand that's all of us is gonna be good
here we go here we go - I want to go off
and write on your table you can write um
I know you love this table
I hate this table
if you're still on the heart
I forgot I don't I don't even remember
matters like I know how to spell
remember when I wrote already oh we
think is zero well we bought time wait
where's the glue oh there it is a camera
hold on hello
they just couldn't be great I'm here
like will you be my Valentine on that I
see discard you're gonna probably be
like no is one of my best Valentine's
Day memories and it was after a long
last game I got Chinese takeout and I
watched binge watch like the whole
series of Merlin a little Marlon is what
what what what
Justine hello Marlon take 18 fantasy
show ah
do you think I'd like it yeah what's it
about well first off the actors are
gorgeous one guy there's you know the
King Arthur and Merlin that actor who
plays Merlin I think he's like Irish oh
oh he's really cute it's really good is
it on Netflix I don't know where it is
right now I bet I think I think I
watched on Bloor necklace I hang it on
there Syl okay I waited a long time say
it maybe on both okay okay I'm writing
you a note now I can't believe you
having I'm being kind for my one-year
you know what I thought was going to all
my gosh or glue everywhere okay right
here I thought less always be so funny
is to rent all of the scary Valentine's
Day movies Oh like the like
successful thrillers listen we met
Valentine or whatever I rented all of
these movies and then I watched it with
my girlfriend and I had nightmares oh my
gosh that's probably not a good thing I
mean I think I'm gonna have nightmares a
premiere are you after I look at my card
and say what looks like you resin say as
you saw my car
no I promise okay I'm going to write
even though I've had a right on your
table with this marker hope you don't do
that cuz I know he's the Sherman kind of
ride around all these decorations I'm
created I'm gonna write you a poem okay
I can't play with the poem wow this is a
pretty big home I'm writing oh I
misspelled something
it's okay I think I think I misspelled
your name because I forgot oh I'm
guessing I'm so excited I can't wait for
you to see this okay look wow I can't
this is katakana I can't
fun oh very good you like that without a
card company
oh yeah people are gonna want these okay
okay wait oh oh oh I found some stickers
oh there I did up here these are self
adhesive so you don't got to find the
tape is like a manga oh no I'm gonna use
it to dust off my face I feel like I
needed
we've got bare spot kidding of that
oh that's what oh that's what it's a
group the only way Twitty wanted a
clunker is amazing okay oh really hard
it to write them right along here after
you roll I got that on with people my
gosh
okay I see oh I keep igloo
you are so me you can kill me with a
lorry yes sorry okay
oh my gosh okay here's an empty spot I'm
gonna put it all the way up here flip
are you even is even touching paper with
I think I ran outta space for my
beautiful you have construction paper no
would you like yeah we're okay oh sorry
oh there we go as long oh yeah I can't
see the color no don't know what the
colors are I'm going to I'm not do
another heart the pink ones are going to
be a little how about your products
attached okay don't look at my fingers
oh maybe I got a big heart for safety
you should it feels like some like war
hotdog or something this does not feel
like a heart this is if you're like ah
so much Florida really it doesn't not
doesn't feel like let me try it again -
try again is oh you know you can we've
got lots of paper and here we go here we
go let me try another heart oh okay here
we go random and we go and then just a
little on top
oh no little already up Oh mom's blue we
are we're okay
okay oh yeah I need that you I mean I
don't want to say like my cards done by
the cards on okay my card series Oh
heavy that's been quite red angel' I'm
trying to find a corner here oh yeah
this is great
I'm feeling oh man I know I've written
all myself many times
hey girl how do I hope stigma I think I
keep touching your bird oh you
well she's tape sticker day I know I
don't
Lewbert because I put some stickers on
her I've got a lot of you I field
artistic reasons flowing from my body
wait okay our amazing woman dancing yeah
I'm taking me but are you giving me
something no okay well I did my cards
done okay
oh yeah oh yeah because I think I've run
out of space like I feel like it's very
as a substantial card this card is going
to be a surprise for you and me okay we
are okay here's the big reveal
I'm going to give you my card to give me
your card and okay okay oh this here
it's very nice on it oh it is this is
very heavy one two three just seems so
few in my life
although I tried it going on but it
wouldn't stay so then I just put
stickers
oh my little more it's not what to say
because roses are red violets are blue I
love you I ran out of room
oh it's a very very beautiful Pete me oh
that's nice I thought they look like a
better heart in my head this was like an
amazing hurt hated it I mean it's not
bad she looks like um we're a jelly bean
where I was for that did you end up
putting Florida on there I don't work
for it away I saw they didn't use it
it's really good I mean like take a look
at my words where did the heart I don't
even know where it went
why don't you guys find it but this is
something that I'm going to get framed
and I mean it's great it was made with a
lot of love bottle of look at this
design class what happy actually looks
like a cute little card nope I forgot
where I left off on your name that came
about right there and I've been given a
big please enemy anything that wants it
to be my heart this is a heart yes I get
it now like a circle no oh yeah lemon
turned out
no but I get it look at this is even a
card you guys it's Wow
I mean this is a lot of love look at
this look greed what do we have here oh
you are sweet like a treat let's go eat
ha ha I mean it's a quite an enticing
invitation I love it
Oh do you want to be and is on the back
well where's the balance oh yeah
November he had my Valentine
of course well you got a circle it on
the back oh I got a circle at the end
yeah I gave you a couple marker options
and you choose is like so well thought
out and interactive that was the check
yes and no how there are fake yes or no
do I Circle it in yeah yeah I ran out of
space on the back see it says yes or no
right interactive cool okay so we're
going to see ya barks oh and I am you
guys have seen the best Valentine pay
cards while blindfolded and riding with
our opposite hands yeah it's good it's
incredible I'm extremely proud of so
many perilous I was really afraid I'm
gonna cut my finger off that was only
wait yeah we're having a blind child is
terrified really scary you have to feel
where the scissor is and then move your
thumb back yeah you just cut around it
and you pretend like a big space around
it nothing I want to look like a jelly
bean this is what I was looking for this
is my one hahaha oh the red one wow it's
so thick paper no I did calibrate this
one it was my desk to get all these
little things out of my way oh my gosh
with that
cool oh so sad I know is there well I
mean I wouldn't even know the glue stick
paper you know endless sir you can roll
my help that rose say oh yeah give us an
extra support I've added two if I act
with them it's you know add value
yeah odd well I think that's it mm-hmm
well thank you guys so much watching you
hoping to have a wonderful Valentine's
Day and let us know what you think in
the comments below about our beautiful
cards I think they're incredible when oh
boy
check out our fun video that I did on
bros channel it's going to be great
yeah they're gonna love it you tried all
kinds of Valentine's Day candy I all
thank you guys for watching I'll see you
later bye we'll just fill these up I'm
done I'm done trying to be precise and
not make a mess I am done with that
there will be no more precision thick of
it speak of a precision there we go
I tried I tried a top board able to do
it anymore
close in places
[Music]